bonsoir
vous êtes aujourd'hui l'artiste français
le plus vendu dans le monde
pourtant vous venez d'un milieu aux
antipodes de l'art contemporain celui
des affaires du business vous avez fait
fortune dans l'immobilier mais cette
villa avait fini par vous lasser et
cette histoire vous l'a raconté dans un
livre intitulé Pourquoi j'ai cassé les
codes publié chez Michel Lafont
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors Richard vous êtes né le 19 janvier
1966 à Paris mais infirmière devenu prof
de yoga superbobin cool votre maman
du quinoa du riz sarrasin
je connais le truc et la macrobiotique
le carton enfin toutes les toilettes
sèches alors votre père finira lui
animateur de tout opérateur est pas
beaucoup d'ambition pas trop non c'est
pas une admiration folle pour lui quand
vous êtes petit non malheureusement non
on va voir pourquoi à l'école vous êtes
brillant mais vous êtes révolté contre
la mort vous avez des colères monstres
ou taper des points contre les murs quoi
vous aviez peur de mourir ou peur de
devoir mourir un jour
de devoir mourir un jour c'était très
violent très très très fort chez moi
mais tout petit en fait j'ai eu
conscience de notre finalité finalement
très jeune très tôt alors dès la
maternelle vous mettez à fabriquer des
petits animaux en terre cuite voilà
c'est ça des hippopotames des éléphants
ça plaît aux gens ça peut énormément
puis un peu fayot donc ça peut au
maîtresse au directrice ça veut dire
quoi
ça dépend
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors en fait vous arrêtez de faire ces
petits animaux en terre cuite pourquoi
parce que ça vous rendez un peu ridicule
auprès des filles ben c'est pas très
rock'n'roll quoi il y a un moment elle a
pris adolescence il y a mieux quoi
alors la maison vous subissez la
violence physique de votre père il vous
bat et il vous lance des objets visage
sans prévenir c'était comme ça celui
prenait c'était un peu irrationnel pour
des choses très graves il y avait aucune
réaction et pour des choses complètement
anodines c'est
pas pourquoi ça vient voilà c'est en
fait vous grandissez dans l'insécurité
avec une mère qui fait comme elle peut
pour compenser mais c'est très compliqué
et des parents qui s'entendent pas non
plus assez ambiance aussi envers pas
uniquement vers moi alors votre mère
finira par divorcer votre père me payera
pas la pension alimentaire évidemment et
voilà vous avez pas de thunes le
problème c'est que vous passez votre
enfant dans les beaux quartiers de la
capitale au milieu des gosses de riches
sans argent
c'était difficile oui parce que ils
avaient tout moi j'avais rien vous
écrivez une poésie à 11 ans je voudrais
une Porsche quand je serai grand il va y
avait pas que ça mais c'est vrai quand
je relis cette poésie je suis je suis
très surpris je crois qu'aujourd'hui je
serais pas capable de la réécrire donc
déjà mais j'avais ce rêve effectivement
de réussite ou de compenser peut-être
que je n'avais pas à 14 15 ans vous
devenez un gérable vous passez venu au
Palace au privilège au Bus Palladium
vous fréquentez les rallies mondains
vous flirter avec de riches héritières
mais vous avez jamais de quoi payer un
café ou une place de cinéma non non
c'est vrai et puis et puis j'essaie de
masquer ça quand même comme mes amis ont
des chaussures de grande marque moi
j'arrive à me payer des imitations etc
donc souvent j'essaie de que ça c'est
toujours peur qu'on démarre un peu honte
de tout ça quoi donc c'est assez c'est
assez compliqué j'ai d'ailleurs j'ai eu
des ruptures peut-être à cause de ça
mais c'est moi qui avait c'était
personnel je pense pas que complexé par
un vrai complexe situation sociale en
fait oui même si les amis c'était en 6e
c'était des amis qui me payaient le le
cinéma enfin tout qui se venaient donc
c'était compliqué après un bac S un dog
d'économie et un MBA in situ vous passez
donc des petits boulots au business
et là vous vous lancez dans l'immobilier
et vous ne tardez pas à gagner beaucoup
de blé vous devenez amener Maker en fait
ce que je faisais c'est que je racheté
des
immeubles des biens qui étaient un petit
peu délabrés et je les rendais je les
redisais je les rendrai
accessible ou je les rendais plus belle
exactement à 35 ans vous êtes riche
marié père de 4 enfants vous avez 300
mètres carrés avenue Foch meublé design
vous roulez en Ferrari vous achetez des
Warhols des combats des Armands des
clins en fait c'est la vie dont vous
rêviez étant enfant quoi complètement
vous avez déjà réalisé à 35 ans
finalement le rêve de votre vie oui sur
le papier mais au fond vous sentez cerné
par les obligations vous êtes assaillis
toujours par vos angoisses de mort
et chaque fois que vous le pouvez vous a
donné à la peinture à la sculpture en
fait vous auriez voulu être un artiste
vous en rendez compte à ce moment là
pour pouvoir faire mon numéro
en juin 2003 vous pilotez votre Ferrari
lorsque vous êtes saisis d'un vertige
vous vous arrêtez sur le bas-côté et là
vous avez une espèce de révélation comme
Saint Paul sur le chemin de Damas il
vous apparaît impensable de continuer
comme ça plus longtemps au bord du burn
out j'étais très mal à l'aise et
finalement personne pouvait le
comprendre parce qu'effectivement avec
cette
réussite en fait cette image en tout cas
parce que parfaite enfin voilà et moi
finalement je suis très malheureux je
suis très très malheureux c'est du
bonheur mais qui ne vous satisfait pas
en fait très malheureux là vous repensez
au figurines en terre cuite que vous me
donniez enfant et une image s'impose le
crocodile c'est un animal qui a traversé
toutes les airs qui étaient moins de
quelqu'un un cerveau reptilien il y
avait un rapport entre l'homme la
violence animale je voulais qu'il y
avait quelque chose d'assez qui
m'impressionnait beaucoup voilà votre
vie vient de basculer la fabrication du
crocodile va tourner à l'obsession ou
vis tous les ateliers toutes les
fonderies venez dingue de cette histoire
de crocodiles et à la maison ça râle
c'était le crocodile quoi en fait
c'était que j'avais complètement
déraillé il y a pas qu'elle est très
sceptique votre épouse
que c'est petit alors vous poursuivez
votre rêve de démocratiser la sculpture
donc de faire des oeuvres qui est une
allure de jouets ou persévérer là-dedans
et en 2004 vous mettez en vente donc le
crocodile rouge alors évidemment vous
avez un look à l'époque de golden boy
quoi Le Garric comme vous allez le voir
et vous prend pour un marchand et il dit
bah c'est pas mal votre truc je voulais
prendre mais on va les faire signer par
un artiste reconnu c'est super vexant et
c'est oui c'est une espèce d'humiliation
mais notre côté bon j'ai accusé le coup
et puis bon j'ai avec l'expérience et ce
que j'ai vécu avant j'ai dit bon bah
c'est pas comme ça qu'il va falloir
faire on va changer son fusil d'épaule
en même temps Jeff Koon s'il était
trader
oui mais c'est peut-être pas présenté
non plus
alors au début vous vendez à perte on
retrouve le businessman vendez le
crocodile à 990 euros c'est du dumping
en fait tout à fait c'est jumping
c'était je me suis dit que si les gens
et ben peuvent l'acquérir ça peut à
garantir c'est un risque aussi vous avez
raison quand on voit moi la première
fois que j'ai vu une de vos œuvre avenue
Matignon je suis resté pendant 10
minutes devant la vitrine entraînement
et c'est quoi ce truc là quoi c'était un
crocodile d'ailleurs alors bientôt vos
œuvres s'arrachent comme des petits
pains et là vous augmentez vos prix bah
j'essaie de récupérer un petit peu
l'investissement en fait le crocodile en
rouge en noir en rose en bleu en violet
et puis même en or en diamant il y a un
mec qui vous achète un crocodile serti
de diamant ou en or enfin tomber sur des
gens qui ont de l'argent à dépensé quoi
oui comme beaucoup d'argent mais qui
sont séduits aussi parce que
il y a de l'émotion j'essaie de donner
de l'émotion de lisibilité qui est
immédiate dans les œuvres on comprend
tout de suite alors vous faites un ours
nous et le fameux welcome donc on voit
ici c'est super beau vous installez vos
créations dans les endroits de luxe à
Deauville à Val-d'Isère Courchevel
Saint-Tropez Miami Los Angeles malin
quoi oui enfin moi il y avait une autre
vocation la vocation de d'installer des
œuvres à ciel ouvert et gratuitement
c'est que tout le public parce que c'est
un truc il y a pas que il y a de tout
sorte de public et c'est que
gratuitement jamais en fait le musée au
spectateur et qui peuvent payer par
service pendant photo et c'est des vrais
attractions aujourd'hui ah les prix
montant il y a une pin-up qui s'est
vendu 15 millions 15 millions c'est en
or massif en normal un armateur italien
d'où le prix c'est déjà le prix de la
matière première là c'est quand même
accessible
[Rires]
je cherche aussi à faire des sculptures
qui ont des prix aussi bas qui sont
accessibles puisque je fais des
sculptures aussi pour je fais une
collaboration avec un parc d'attraction
une Sèvres souris et on a une oeuvre qui
se vend à 45 euros
[Applaudissements]
Michel vous connaissez le travail de
Richard
est très généreux parce que quand il y a
des soirées pour l'humanitaire de
charité il offre ses oeuvres et voilà il
est généreux c'est qu'il est
systématiquement là dans toutes les
soirées caritatives
de l'immobilier c'est bien
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu